I don't know about this I don't see like
my favorite actor is like Johnny Depp or
Harrison Ford 20 hi exfoliant you know
this is what you behind-the-scenes no
you destroy it you sure just look you're
not an ally to me just please open my
room in about this okay so good like
what what's wrong with you fake
we're exfoliating right now that me um a
means we're just opening these pores and
making them glow all around do what them
I got a go rock climbing in like 20
minutes
hi I'm Greg and I am Nate Nate heartily
the Nate Hartley and the Greg album
together in one video to unite the
forces of good and also be sexy
well I'm like the sexy one you're the
sexy one
I am the onlooker of your second yeah I
just look on my number two yeah yeah I
should take a number two honestly I had
a lot of brand yet a lot of great
thinking of that is a boy adventurer a
turd oh it's red band is gonna be scary
it's only 30 seconds may we can handle
it it's like every sexual encounter I've
had is requested from someone on Twitter
Kurusu Kuras you know the free stream is
what cast a bi well I don't want to
watch your scabby I just don't turn away
you just told me about a 17 minute rape
scene you watched you can watch yeah and
irreversible it's Casper no it's a
different thing this is art time in
America right I won't turn away
surprised the things aside any we're
looking tell me what you see
[Music]
ah going on thanks for the entry can you
bid
no that's good very handsome wouldn't
save me why whatever mean why they put
the enterings on over the footage the
trailer to protect the virgin eyes like
me I gotta find a different video next
episode alright so this one has the end
screens at the end but they're off to
the side
great let's watch it again great I can
absorb this down really middle less than
second then you're looking tell me what
you see great back
[Music]
[Music]
that's great okay throw aah bang out of
eyeball literally ice up freaks me out
more than anything because I think
glasses is a very young age and so like
if this is protection knives go through
a lot okay so like this gets is like rid
of maybe bugs and stuff but a knife
this isn't protecting me from nice yeah
John Carpenter is really cool though and
it should be damn right yeah so do
nothing of what the films really about
but what I will say is other than sound
quality's having a little amateur the
film shot really well yeah y'all really
long and the practical effects look
amazing do you find that like films
starting to go more towards like an 80s
feel like like honestly our over phase
of scauldron yeah like people love
things a little bit all dat about their
past
yeah like The Goonies or like et yeah
they're all just like them as Amblin the
steel brand I'll just like trying to do
that like super 8 rise maybe super 8
started and then it's like that kind of
started the resurgence oh yeah and now
they're coming back with like really
cool Ranger things are special
definitely yeah and there's like movies
that come out to just remind kind of
adult stranger things like a stranger
things it's like scary whatever this
looks like like graphic image a this is
like stranger or say yeah well it's one
thing that it doesn't matter like a
carpenter film of the 80s yeah I think I
like this thing or something yeah
exactly was like the kind of the bubble
was a of like a body or yes I pose yeah
the bubbly thing the I the feel of guts
and I like the way did their like
creature effects totally that look and
it feels like this kind of eerie dread
and 80's music they had going over like
and cuz everyone loved that that kind of
music that Nene's music is [ __ ] bomb
and then that shot of just all those
people in white sheets just a nice cameo
from the KKK yeah like she's great I'm
UVB billboards
in the middle of a routine patrol
officer Daniel Carter happens upon a
blood-soaked figure limping down a
deserted stretch of road he rushes the
young man to a nearby rural hospital
staff by a skeleton crew a lot of
adjectives yeah I want to discover that
patients and personnel like someone took
the time to ripen soon to discover that
patients and personnel are transforming
into something inhuman lose the horrid
testifies power leads the other
survivors on a hellish voyage into the
subterranean depths of the hospital in a
desperate bid to end the nightmare
before it's too late
oh yeah that's how it sounds like a type
of 80s horror like contain thriller all
inside of like this one hospital or
maybe just a little bit outside of it
totally but it's like good she'll freak
me out
did you ever play a game call is a
separate thing but like Alan Wake this
is okay there's it reminds me of that
kind of style or like even a heavy rain
have you played that it's a really cool
game and it's just video games are
turning into movies and movies are
turning into videos I will watch I'm a
baby when it comes to horror movies but
like this is this looks really beautiful
it looked like yeah looks like an
experience yeah exactly yeah it looks
more than just we're trying to scare you
yes like these people are passionate
filmmakers who wanted to capture
something very specific you can always
feel that especially people who go out
of their way for practical effects
whether that's a big-budget movie or a
low-budget film when you go out of your
way for practical for crazy effects
these are passionate do you want to do
something to make the leaves an
impression yeah and the practical effect
of the bubbly stomach actually lives
just from Taco Bell oh yeah
Packers need a lot of talk about yeah
beanie cheese burritos digitized savages
Taco Bell oh yeah but it's delicious
it's delicious oh they're like worth
their winner it is delicious
it scares me but it's delicious I'll
watch that the boys that's cool boy know
what all right well guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects Nate
Hartley is Nate Hartley on Instagram
it's like Jer got Harley made hard
at night hardly be obliged to that I
know I don't need these eases the stack
this is the best Madison Avenue the
spares not even real just a one notice
do the comedian so I met this guy he's
an actor comedian writer he's very
talented
follow him on Instagram where I'm sure
he has interesting things on there I'm
sure he's a funny man you thought you
people can pull off this hat you can
pull it off right now you a Jewish with
this hat I look Italian with is that
thank you
your and your beautiful Italian on a
beautiful Jew you are Jewish who cares
doesn't matter we're all the same race
truck